こんにちははじめ社長です今日は
とんでもないゲストの方が来ていただいておりませんどうぞ
うーってくれたあーうードゥロスよくよろしくお願いします
お母さんが社員くださいってパティ今日は草なぎさんが来ていただいているということ
で
だろはい
ブーブー社長かあぁすごくいい tube here 余計あにょん
入ってくるんですかねはいそれで u 2バーってこうなんか
デビュー作品というかこの動画で有名になったんで動画があるんで
僕のその動画が5分ロってゆう
はい
するいましたよロスターもエッグデビュー
そういうするということなので一緒に行ってみませんかやりたいやれやれだ匹はウサギ
さんとスライムフローを作っていきたいとおもいまーいい奴だったさ
結構イケメンだよ
別やゆチューバーならなくて良かったねえじゃあ分数が来ればなったのは知らせたい
はずらせたいですね
ぽこ本当に入れるくらいのプーぐらいの大きなスライムを作っていきたいとおもいます
はーいまず準備するのがお水30 l あと洗濯のりが30リットルを
スライムの作り方分かってるんだねー
その流れはあっ
[音楽]
ん
加工に素材または子が持っている
こちらが3つだいたい3000円取るぐらいですはいこちらが洗濯のり30リットル
ぐらいになります混ぜていきましょう
おいっちやー
はいいい感じだと思います当院で言ってもいいでしょ高城さんってなんてお呼びしたら
いいですか
もうあのキュッポンに冬を感じるか
ています
ん
ありませんもうちょっとたラストですか
+所得ラストですじゃあラスト入れますよ
teen
ヤッター入りました
なんで一番終了ねー wii これで
だからこのスライムにろうをつけていきます色はい強くを好きな色は何色ですか
そうですねやっぱりストライプって言ったら緑なんですけど緑にしようかな
はい the 紫にしていきます油漬けってはい
なんで聞いたんだよだと会おう混ぜると紫になるんだよぉー
やばやばいやばいやばい
ああやばいねーちゃんと紫ですね紫だねぇ
続いて次なんですけどもう多さという砂みたいなのかですけどねこれはお湯に溶かして
いきますおおーー
15リットルのお湯に入れ200mg の方さを打ち込んで質していきます
[拍手]
人気てきた分ける溶けるこれでとりあえず4冊勇気は完成ですなさ黄色い水2 o さん
を混ぜたお湯を合わせて完成ですああああいうの
まだ
まあ[ __ ]まで飲ま0マ0マ0マ0正0正050倍さあここを使うの頃は
[音楽]
ブーブー思いますこれ大成功ですよ
うっわえええ
すらティン分はいとりわけてスライム無事完成でやったぁー
やっぱり頭より上で何も作ったんですけどもじゃあ肇社長
ここはここはもうぜひいうか入ったことあるんで
パンツを是非一度大変して会見し頂けると嬉しいなますよだね赤黒だからねはいじゃあ
ちょっと
はい
ハイローカーをねじゃあもういいでしょはい
準備とと思いましたやってますありがとうございます
24さんの配布中 barbie を決めしてはいぜひ取材に風呂に入っいただけると
嬉しいです
はい
せっかく5んで観客に使って
残って
スーツかそうですよね誰か入るだけじゃつまんない捧げますよね
的な問題そうですよねドアカーみたいなそうよって言って0
あれだけ食べてじゃないから良いはいこれですか配布と申します
スプーンあった
お願いしましたここで使い切った
うん
a
びっくりしたわー
ドッキリ声
裏九の財政かー
open car めちゃくちゃ怖いでしょ笑
他所へ by 経済マドリエくん
none
プレートを入れましたいや僕霊木ドンジョンバックやってる
あなたはいくつ持ってございますさあ
me
dee
wh
びっくりしましたびっくりしとさあ
bobo 全力切るから入り masa ポリプもういい愛 ah 国会で家まで病気
でしてはい
入ってくださいはい行きばあさん2
ああああああああああああ
だーらー
ありがとうありがとうこの模様はアブマン tv の72時間テレビで皆さん中でば
住んで
抜き出さうわああああああ皆さんお楽しみに
まあを出す日に果てない空